the Joe Rogan experience yeah but I know
he was really kind of squatting there
and some crazy farming Brazil horses
that's not lenny Kravitz's there's a
whole video online we see him in his
estate in Brazil he's amazing he's so
[ __ ] talented well are you gonna go
my way
maybe - he's so talented he's so
talented there's a film where he
produces Mick Jagger's record Wow record
for Mick Jagger there's no way oh wow
it's incredible are you super you can
tell just when Jamie cuz that's an
amazing video because you can tell like
what kind of a person he is by following
him around this house where he talks
about like what these things in his
house mean to him like what like little
pieces of art things that someone left
him think people you know the things
that have like real significant meaning
to means talking about why and what they
it was Architectural Digest okay
yeah people try to be weird [ __ ]
ranch in Arizona a ranch in Brazil what
is this one when you talk about levels
this how is this dude let's let's guess
let's be conserving and say 73 yeah
might be 76 right yeah here we go
drum roll please come on Oh Aubrey de
Grey podcast I do have a like I feel
like these people are joyful you know I
think that that's the anti aging
contingency is as propagating joy I
think you're right and I think with Mick
Jagger one of the big things is that
makjang is like really really into
fitness
oh yeah he works out twice a day he does
vodka he does oh I see what's up like
you got to keep this [ __ ] boat on the
river you gotta keep this boat on the
river and he gets after it he does it's
legendary he does dancing dancing is
everything is a lot his heart so if you
want to see Mick Jagger that's some
dancing in the streets right there he's
got bad hips he's gonna stand still no
this guy's [ __ ] hustlin realizes what
he's doing do you guys dance do you
dance
um I do this is my my thing is when I'm
in my studio I work all by myself and I
dance crazy [ __ ] yeah Gary yeah
absolutely
I'm busted out someday Gary awesome
yeah why not man you desert to your own
sounds making my own I don't dance
enough I dance at home alone often but I
should get out and like
exercise too sure and it's not just a
physical exercise it's like a spiritual
exercise in that URI you're enjoying
yourself though that word spiritual so
poisoned by crystals and [ __ ] freedom
[Applause]